(rock music)
- Now it's time for
tonight's hashtag wars.
(cheering)
(dramatic music)
- Pinewood Derby drive-by.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(bell dinging)
Jon?
- Eating brownies.
- [David] Nice, I like that.
(laughter)
- [Chris] Points Jon Daly.
(bell dinging)
Nicole?
- Dick s'mores.
(laughter and cheering)
- Points and I hope the next time
you're in a crowded
room you shout that out
for no reason.
(dramatic electronic music)
(bell dinging)
- [Chris] Rich?
- (Bleep)-able cats.
(laughter)
- Wait a minute, hang on Rich.
Ya coulda just Googled cats.
(laughter)
Points.
(bell dinging)
Yes, Brett?
- (Bleep)-able squirrels.
(laughter)
Points, Horatio?
- Butt plus battery life.
- Yep, points.
(laughter)
(bell dinging)
Rich?
- How to Google.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
Points, Horatio?
- Prersonal precipes.
(laughter)
- Points, Rich?
- If I beat off in the backyard,
will I be seen by Google street view?
(laughter)
(dramatic music)
(bell dinging)
- Yeah, Jim?
- Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory Outlet.
- Yeah, points, points.
Whitney Cummings?
- Moby Dick pics.
- Yes, points.
Chris?
No, it's Whitney again.
- Ah, it's Fifty Shades of Orange.
- Yes, points.
- Thing doesn't work!
(laughter)
It doesn't work!
- Chris Delia, Chris Delia?
- Of Mice and Men, yous guys.
(laughter)
Come on, man.
(cheering)
- Points, Chris Delia?
- The Adventures of
Huckleberry Fuhgeddaboudit.
- [Chris] Yeah, point.
- Come on.
- Points, Whitney Cummings?
- Catch 22 Venereal Diseases.
(laughter)
- Points, Chris Delia?
- Mrs. Dalloway, She Blew Me.
- [Chris] Yeah, points.
- Alright.